[Musique]
plus d'amour
L'amour c'est comme le jogging dans les
bois ton fait 10 fois le tour tu reviens
toujours Au mme
endroit où tu jures qu'on ne réprimandera pas
pas puis un jour tu dis tout
bas
qu'est-ce qu'il a Mon
cur qu'est-ce qu'il B IL est
fou Je le connais Plus du tout Moi qui
tu le connais même
cur qu'est-ce qu'il a Mon petit
cur qu'est-ce qu'il bat qu'est-ce qu'il
fout cit genre 30 l'imitation et
[Musique]
toute joue les
cou vo qui joue les casse
maudits lundi
[Musique]
cur tu avais l'air de rien et IL y avait
rien de spécial dans
l'air Je me satais très bien j'avais
fait le plein
d'ordine et la que tu me ranim bement Au
bouche bouche du
sentiment qu'est-ce qu'il a Mon petit
cur qu'est-ce qu'il va IL est
fou Je le reconnaissance Plus du tout Moi qui
tu le connais même
cur qu'est-ce qu'il a Mon petit
cur qu'est-ce qu'il B qu'est-ce qu'il
foutu
c'est tel genre 30 l'heure l'imitation
et
tous ceux qui les jouent
caseu qui les joue
cas mon
[Musique]
cur la fin de nous deux Je veux pas
savoir quand
viendra
plus Je veux des adieux comme dans le
le showbiz quand ça se termine
pas Je veux des souvenirs la peine pour
quand IL et aura Plus
rappel qu'est-ce qu'il a Mon petit cur
quel effet who lui
faire lui qui était tout parfait a
baiser d'un
médecin
qu'est-ce qu'il va mon petit
cur qu'il bat comme Un
s qu'l'amour qu'il a le droit
l'j'ai le sang dessus
Dessous mon cur à pris un
cou de
[Musique]
cur
que